(brisk string music)
- [Woman] Walking down this
quiet street in Brooklyn,
you'd never know that
inside this building,
within this tiny apartment, music is made.
♪ Nobody reads from the Book of Job ♪
♪ At the church where
me and my grandma go ♪
♪ Nobody sees the trouble I know ♪
♪ But I know that
trouble's gonna find me ♪
- [Woman] Meet Evan and Luke.
They're longtime friends and roommates.
- Evan and I have been
living together here for,
how many years have we
been living together, man?
- [Evan] About a year and a half?
- A year and a half?
- [Woman] And once a month,
in only about 500 square feet,
they manage to pile in up to 60 musicians
for the ultimate recording session.
- I think we should put five
or six people in the bathroom.
(cello scales)
- For each arrangement, we
record it in about three hours,
and post it online.
(percussion rhythm)
- [Luke] A lot of people's
reactions are that
it seems crazy, and it is crazy.
- [Woman] To pull this off,
first, they have to uproot
their humble abode.
- Anything that is not involved
in making music has to go.
(drill whirring)
- [Luke] We take all the furniture out,
we take most of the doors off,
it's just all about making as much room
and as much sight lines as possible.
- [Evan] It really just looks like chaos;
there's mic stands everywhere;
the floor is littered with music stands.
- I'm a little worried about this, though.
- [Evan] There's not a
single inch to spare.
- [Woman] And that's because
they make way for the strings,
woodwinds, horns, percussion,
and a full chorus.
♪ Find me ♪
Yeah, that's a marimba in the kitchen.
(marimba notes)
But, why?
- [Evan] I wanted an opportunity
to record a bunch of
people at the same time.
Luke wanted an opportunity to
hear his arrangements played,
so we just invited a bunch of people over.
- [Woman] And although
it seems unconventional,
there's a reason for the madness.
- [Evan] We're trying to change the way
that you might see an orchestra play.
There is a special dynamic
and a feeling in the room that
you won't get in a recording
studio or in a public venue.
(wind instruments playing and clapping)
- [Woman] It's this unique
sound and sense of community
that has attracted musicians
from all over the country to participate.
- [Luke] There's definitely
something really exciting
about the idea that this
really shouldn't be possible.
- [Evan] It's a really unique experience,
and I think that people are drawn to that.
- [Woman] And so, they keep at it.
♪ It'll find me ♪
♪ Find me ♪
- [Luke] It's a real kind of
jarring, wonderful experience
every time and we love it.
- [Woman] And I bet the
neighbors must love it, too.
- They're lucky they're good.
- Hi! Hello, New York City!
(group conversing)
(ding)